LLL do you view it as your job to
promote the movies that you act in yes
and I give credit for this great quote
to carry an asana who's an acting coach
and an actress and she told me that when
she books a job Carrie says look I'm a
marketing partner for the life of your
movie that really adds value because i
think what it's about is an actor yes
hopefully i can do the job that you
hired me to do but what can i do beyond
that to add value to that how can i
doubt only meet your expectations but
exceed them and i can do that by being
your marketing partner for that movie
forever and ever and ever it's part of
my job to have you seen that trait from
other actors some some not so much
something that it's you know kind of
grubbing to get down in the trenches and
do the tweets and write about the movie
and that they just want to come in and
be the actor actress and I can't speak
for them but for me it doesn't work I
get much more play and I book more
business when I'm a marketing partner
for the movie because what's good for
the movie is good for me it's the way
that I see it why do you think people
don't want to do the promotional part i
don't i don't think it's that they don't
want to work i think it's that they
don't see it as a part of their job or
they think that it enhances their status
not to be evolved in the promotion but
at my level of acting you know i'm not
an a-lister and i can't afford not to be
a full partner because what if the film
does something really well you know
there's film that just ran it South by
Southwest yes I am going to be your
marketing partner I'm there and any time
they include me on any other publicity I
write the director and I say thank you
for including me I know you didn't have
to do that here's what I'm doing so
don't take it as an expectation that the
movie is going to build you up your job
is to build the movie up your job
doesn't in when you step off set in some
senses you know it only begins
I get 100 credits and so I've got a
hundred marketing jobs as long as those
things are around big or small it's my
job wherever I can to push them
you